in the lobby of Ramsey solution
solutions Nikolas and Dara are whether
hey guys how are you hi how are you
welcome welcome where're you guys from
we're from Mamaroneck New York and
Westchester just outside of the city
yeah very cool what's just a beautiful
area yes very nice we're good to have
you guys in you're here to do your debt
free screams early Iowa fun how much
have you paid off we pay off 30 mm 42
dollars and 10 months good for you and
your range of income during that time we
went from about ninety thousand to one
hundred and fifty five thousand Wow big
jump what was a big jump he got a great
raise and then he ended up taking a new
job Oh a great race and a new job yeah
there we go with a great race yeah there
we go
very good good good what do you do for a
living I'm a photographer I own my own
business I shoot families and kids Oh
wonderful and I'm a project manager for
a construction company we do tile and
marble installations in New York oh very
nice I notice well good for you guys so
what kind of debt was the thirty three
thousand bucks
we had about six thousand on a credit
card we had ten thousand dollars in
student loans and I we ended up getting
a car about a year and a few months ago
for $16,000 that was the big dog yes
okay that was during baby step 2
shirring yeah well I called in September
because I kind of had an epiphany and I
was like should we sell my cars we saw
his car which we do and just to put it
lightly you ripped me a new one and it
did not go over well and I walked around
with my tail between my legs for about
two weeks like we got to just do it got
us started what did I tell you that you
shouldn't have bought that car um well I
told you which I shouldn't have I said
you know Dave the whole time I'm sitting
there filling out paperwork I can just
hear you telling me not to do it you go
oh yeah you said well why'd you do it I
said I don't know I'm so sorry you knew
that you interrupted me and you go no
you heard me telling you not to do it so
why do
my god don't be banner be so yeah it's a
featured video on the YouTube channel I
had to stop reading those comments you
know oh we're here
you're here you made it yeah what did
you do with the car you sold it or you
paid out we paid it off
okay that was the $16,000 car I let it
okay yeah right
oh so you're telling me you did this
while you were in baby step two that's
what you told me yeah but yeah that's
why I let you out we were halfway and we
were not really doing it you know and my
car gave out and we didn't have savings
and would bought a car okay and it was
one no I know what now I'm starting to
figure out why I got because I don't
usually just stop somebody yeah
unsuspecting that way but I get it okay
you got me
Wow uh sorry that's okay glad glad you
survived all right I I accept her oh my
gosh so what happened it sounds like
there's two phases to this whole process
emotionally you were kind of lightweight
doing baby step two what got you started
doing that and then was it that phone
call that got you on board and you
decide to go all-in then or what tell me
how this all worked out we were making
decent money you know for our age and
you know what we were doing and we
couldn't find any money at the end of
the month ever and I said this is crazy
we're making too much money to not know
where the money is going so I think with
that compounded on top of this phone
call it got us really jumpstart into
being serious about it okay so you're
but you're kind of working baby step two
literally kind of yeah I mean you knew
what it was yeah had the death all laid
out right we did it was just not intense
correct and I'm a zero to 100 like
there's really no in-between for me so
she's not dipping her foot the pole
she's either on the deck excellent yeah
so I something had to happen kind of
within me not to quote your commercial
someone has to happen inside of you
and that's what happened is I just I was
in bed and I'm like we got a we got to
do something and I was like you know I'm
just gonna call Dave tomorrow and then
that happened the valdosta [ __ ] yeah so
that you so you went after it after that
correct okay yeah I had heard about you
and we
we grew up in Florida in Orlando and my
mom used to listen to you on AM radio
all the time and I would you know I knew
your name and who you were and I didn't
think I don't think it really was visual
of what Dave Ramsey was and you know the
whole plan until we got very involved in
our church and somebody was leading in
class we never took the class but
somebody was leading the class that
conversation may be poor acting okay
cool so how does it feel now that you're
dead free feels amazing for me
personally I never really knew it was
more it was a heart issue
you know belonging to the church like
Dara said we're leaders at our church
and so for us being able to do this I
know God doesn't need our money or want
our money he wants our hearts and so
that was the biggest thing for me that
it's built my faith throughout the
process because in February I told her
we're not gonna be able to be debt-free
by July when we go on this trip and she
said would you have a little faith no
and you know God provided in ways I
can't even imagine Wow so that that was
a really cool part for me is you know it
feels great yeah but I'm looking forward
now to what the future has in store for
us
I mean how have you two been married
through your years we've been together
since we were about 14 when she was
about here and I was about here yeah oh
yeah you know get a little dirt yeah
well we've been married for about for
about three years
yeah okay well congratulations and you
we're so glad you're probably autumn
rush luncheon thanks you two have you
I'm proud of you very well done I'll bet
you parents are by looking at you're
going way to go guys yeah they're all
watching now so that you know cheering
us on so that helps a lot yeah our
friends think we're you know strange but
that's okay we appreciate being weird
you're weird let's say you you by doing
the debt-free scream you kind of get to
you know put it in the face of all those
negative YouTube commenters yeah I know
I know Union yeah this was Christian I
go back and read them
now you just get thumb on him by doing
this and we're you proved them all wrong
I love it yeah we made this trip into a
we're actually going to the Gro
conference at Darjeeling Islands tonight
and so we knew we were coming here for
this so that was why it was kind of our
goal we were coming on this trip so we
just made a road trip on it we we were
in Lexington visiting family this
weekend we came here yesterday and hung
out and met everybody it's just amazing
I watched the show on YouTube every
single day oh my gosh and so walking in
here yesterday it was like seeing people
you know somebody work they were like
did you like a co-worker's I'm like yeah
they're you know I work every day this
is what I do so it's been really surreal
and so we're going to Alabama tonight go
to church of the highlands and then
we're going to Memphis I'm a big Elvis
fan to kind of you know seal off the
trip well Chris and the guys at
highlands are buddies of ours are good
folks amazing you guys have a good time
right ahead
so the one you're in in New York is at
an arc Church up there yep no it's not
oh we kind of follow their model but
it's not yeah technically oh cool yeah
we're super excited well fun you guys
we've got a copy of Chris Hogan's book
for you retire inspire got out the next
chapter in a story to be a millionaire's
and you're well on your way and you're
fun and it's a great great story I love
it thank thanks for joining this all
right Nicholas Adara New York City area
$33,000 paid off in ten months making 90
to 155 and didn't even have to sell the
car all right unless they're a debt free
scream three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
I love it
as fun very well done
so some of you wonder some of you the
ones of you that are listeners that are
the nice people you are always worried
that I'm too tough on somebody and it
turns out you know a good coach will
love you they'll get all up in your
grill right and they'll love you and put
their arm around you when you're
struggling and sometimes I do it the
right way not always but sometimes I
lean on somebody to kick their butt just
when they need it and it turns out for
their best interest hey that's what this
is all about so I don't get
entertainment value on the show out of
just destroying someone there are shows
that do that kind of stuff and we don't
do that if we're after somebody it's for
their own good
it's kind of neat to hear one of them
that actually turned around to it it's
kind of funny and kind of uncomfortable
and awkward but kind of funny too you
know very interesting stuff so remember
I jump it just really railed on this
girl because she was going to buy a
couch hurt her mother-in-law to come
visit I'm like she can sit on the floor
that night I'm at a restaurant she comes
over and says and the lady on the show
this is my mother-in-law I'm going how's
the floor this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
down
[Applause]
[Music]